versión del surf a favor de la adopción
249 en contra 63 el senado aprueba
la madrugada de este jueves francia dio
un paso más hacia la materialización del
pase vacunal como sustitución del pase
sanitario en vigor desde julio de 2021
una medida que excluiría de gran parte
de la vida pública a las personas no
vacunadas el texto original que presentó
la asamblea por iniciativa del gobierno
fue modificado en el senado donde la
oposición es mayoría entre los
principales cambios la suspensión del
pase de vacunación cuando las
hospitalizaciones por kobe 19 sean
inferiores a 10 mil a nivel nacional el
pase vacunal no será exigible a los
menores de edad que podrán seguir usando
un test negativo además el personal de
los locales de restauración y ocio no
podrán realizar controles de identidad
al verificar el carnet de vacunación la
medida ha levantado polémica en francia
por imponer una necesidad periódica de
vacunarse un camino que la agencia
europea del medicamento no ve viable a
largo plazo
wally uso para nadie mientras el uso de
una nueva dosis de refuerzo puede
considerarse de parte de un plan de
contingencia la vacunación repetida en
cortos intervalos no representa una
estrategia sostenible a largo plazo
con una tasa de vacunación parecida a la
de francia el jefe del gobierno español
plantea una estrategia distinta para
combatir el commit 19 y abordarla como
enfermedad endémica por tanto creo que
tenemos las condiciones para que con
precaución poco a poco abriendo se
debate a nivel técnico a nivel de los
profesionales de la salud pero también a
nivel europeo empecemos a evaluar la
evolución de esta enfermedad con
parámetros diferentes a lo que hemos
hecho hasta ahora de momento el gobierno
francés insiste en la medida del pase de
vacunación que será votado
definitivamente este viernes en la
asamblea nacional donde el partido de
macrón la república en marcha y sus
aliados legislan con amplia mayoría